tourists from Canada and Europe flocked
to Cuba's beaches for sun sand and
sports the resorts certainly aren't
overcrowded yet but that could soon
change if the US lifts its trade embargo
2 million Americans a year are expected
to visit and they'll want to do more
than just sunbathe operators of boat
tours and theme parks expect business to
be the Cuban government is counting on
the revenue so it's Tourism Ministry has
ordered this climbing tower from Germany
Hines treasure from upper bavaria plans
and builds climbing structures like this
for clients around the globe this is the
first time he's worked in Cuba so
different fields well it's also a
reference for US foreign countries
always worried that our company is too
small and wonder if we have what it
takes but if you can make it in Cuba you
can make it anywhere there are a lot of
challenges to working here for the treta
has brought along all the parts he'll
need to assemble the tower from Bavaria
the Commission is worth more than one
and a half million euros but he has to
meet a deadline set by the Cuban tourism
ministry as the tower must be ready for
the opening of a new hotel complex
Cuba's Minister of Tourism Manuel
Marrero has invited German
businesspeople to this private reception
German firms are still only minor
players in Cuba but that may be set to
change we need German companies in this
new phase of our economic development
examples of important areas where they
can make a contribution include the
construction of hotels and new tourist
attractions like golf courses American
cars from the 1950s known as yank tanks
are still a common sight on Cuban roads
in many places time seems to have stood
still investment in new buildings and
roads is sorely needed
pretty much the country's entire
infrastructure needs updating but that
hasn't put tourists off some three
million flock to Cuba each year old
Havana is currently being renovated
Hotel Group Kempinski plans to turn this
old building into a five-star hotel
fifty-five years of a u.s. imposed trade
embargo have left their mark much more
renovation is needed and the government
wants investors for prestigious building
projects at a ribbon-cutting ceremony
the Tourism Minister opens a new hotel
with 600 rooms it's operated by Spanish
chain million which runs 26 other
properties on Cuba we're open for
tourists from around the world if the US
trade embargo were lifted we would
welcome more visitors from North America
and we could finally compete on a level
playing field with other vacation
destinations in the Caribbean the
government is seeking foreign business
partners for 53 investment projects but
Cuba still has a centrally planned
economy and there's a lot of bureaucracy
involved still a German Bank was willing
to finance the climbing tower the
project's backers expect to see a return
on their investment within four years
last-minute preparations for the
unveiling this evening the crew are busy
making final touches right up to the
deadline it's taken just eight weeks
from the signing of the contract to the
completion
and they've made it the guests start to
arrive including the Tourism Minister hi
instrudtor is pleased but to make things
easier next time he has one wish my own
crane a good one
I'd ship it over even if it costs the
earth it'll be worth it and it wouldn't
sit idle for long the cuban tourism
ministry plans to order four more of the
climbing towers from germany